have you
ever because you've been a part of some
i mean earlier on like i feel like when
you first got out and when you were
running around with kim and
obviously when you first got on atlantic
the high header days
you were part of some public
altercations yeah um before instagram
yeah right when we would just have to
read about it on allhiphop.com or
whatever the [ __ ] right yeah yeah um
any of those altercations ever result in
you like
maybe 10 15 years later
burying the hatchet with any of those
because i think like uh cause you had a
situation with berg right back in the
day it was
like yeah
but i'm like hit making jim jones got a
whole album coming out so like there's a
thing though and you're a different guy
you know yeah like we
every day we we we trying to uh get to a
place where we
can be better than before right so
i can't like
sit up here and act like
i'm i'm this
actively
involving myself with with some [ __ ]
yeah you've grown
like the same guy you were back there
yeah right it's like it don't it doesn't
even make no sense so anything that i
went through before so you understand
like
i a lot of the things that i i have been
involved with in in the way i was moving
is because i didn't know any different
i didn't know any better like you
understand where my education is coming
from only been in two places in my whole
life i've been in the street and i've
been in prison
and then you get thrown into this
there's the fake ass
that's the only two places i've ever
been in my life
that's it
i had never been in a in a in a
corporate world i had never worked in in
corporate america had never had a a job
anything that i had done
you know
um in my life involved
the streets
and involved you know when i went to
prison then you understand what that is
so what does that teach you these two
places that teach you how to be
violent and teach you how to survive so
it doesn't teach you how to handle your
problems um diplomatically yeah civilly
right so now when i get into industry
and i'm saying all right cool you [ __ ]
is out here idolizing these guys over
here i'm the real thing
so
when i'm getting into things
my only action my only reaction is to
deal with it the way i
only know how to
and then people looking at me like
you bugging
right and i'm saying
yeah i don't want the real thing they're
like nah you could look like you act
like it right we don't really want you
to do it dope right
and it took me a while to kind of really
get that
because for me it was it was
it was staying in a lot of relationships
and it was kind of like
pushing opportunities away from me that
you definitely had a stigma early on but
i knew i've known you right for a long
time so i've known you since like oh
nine twenty two nine and anybody know me
now i've been always been silent
supersonic i've always been always been
solid always been humble always been
you know confident but i've always been
who i was you know and always been solid
right but
you've always had your principles you've
always had right you know look what i
think people know you don't [ __ ] around
with maynard like and that's that's not
a bad thing but you know right i
definitely think that you you definitely
had a stigma right but if you ain't but
if you don't
if you don't hit the top
automatically
and you got to fight for everything that
you got to get
then you then when you when you got that
stigma it chases the money away
you understand so if you if you're a
[ __ ] that
hit straight to the top
and they gotta deal with you she didn't
have to deal with me right
because soon as i have a record
then it was like okay [ __ ]
we don't have to deal with him right
he's not that big
he's not that hot
so
that's the difference so then you you
actually running
the the money away because when you're
not hot
and you're not on fire and you're not
the rapper at the time
then your relationships in in your in
who you are
help you
through that time right you understand
like just being who you are and just
having certain relationships can still
keep you afloat until you until you find
your next situation whether that's a
a
another record or another deal whatever
100 you understand no we see it all the
time yeah no that's fair